how to preprocess pairs of sentences
we have seen enough to tokenize single
sentences and patch them together
in the patch inputs to covers video if
this code
looks unfamiliar to you be sure to check
that video again
here we'll focus on tasks that classify
pairs of sentences
for instance we may want to classify
whether two texts are parentheses or not
here is an example taken from the quora
question pairs data set
which focuses on identifying duplicate
questions
in the first pair the two questions are
duplicates
in the second and of learnt
per classification problem is when we
want to know if two sentences
are logically related or not a problem
called natural language inference
or an li in this example taken from the
multi-nli data set
with a pair of sentences for each
possible label contradiction
not rule or entailment which is a fancy
way of saying the first sentence
implies the second so classifying pairs
of sentences is a problem worth telling
in fact in the clue benchmark which is
an academic benchmark for text
classification
eight of the ten data sets are focused
on tasks using pairs of sentences
that's why models like board are often
pre-trained with a dual objective
on top of the language modeling
objective we often have an objective
related to sentence pairs
for instance during the training that is
shown pairs of sentences
and must predict both the value of
randomly masked tokens
and whether the second sentence follows
from the first hornet
fortunately the tokenizer from the
transformer library has a nice api to
deal with further sentences
you just have to pass them as two
arguments to the tokenizer
on top of the input ids and the
attention mask we studied already
it returns a new field called token type
ids which tells the model which locants
belong to the first sentence
and which ones belong to the second
sentence
zooming in a little bit here are the
input ids
aligned with the tokens they correspond
to the respective token type id
and attention mask we can see the
tokenizer also added special tokens
so we have a cls token the tokens from
the first sentence
a septuagen that occurs from the second
sentence
and the final step token if we have
several pairs of sentences
we can tokenize them together by passing
the list of first sentences
then the list of second sentences and
all the keyword arguments we studied
already
like padding equal to zooming in as a
result we can see how the tokenizer
added padding to the second pair of
sentences
to make the two outputs the same length
and properly dealt with token type ids
and attention masks for the two
sentences
this is an all ready to pass through
model